[موسيقى]
نحن نشجع على النوم الصحي
ومن المفارقات أننا
نبقى مستيقظين
هذا هو مختبر النوم بمستشفى جبل سيناء
في مدينة نيويورك والناس الذين يعملون
هنا يعرفون الكثير عما يحدث
في دماغك في الليل  إنهم يطلق عليهم
تقنيات النوم ويقولون إنها واحدة من
أفضل الوظائف التي حصلوا عليها على الإطلاق ،
وعليهم البقاء مستيقظين طوال الليل للقيام بذلك ،
أنا لويس سأكون تقنيتك الليلة
لذلك حاولنا مواكبة  ليروا
ما يحدث داخل المختبر بينما
ينام الجميع ، لذا هذا
ما سنرتديه الليلة ،
حسنًا ،
أنا بومة ليلية بشكل
طبيعي ولذا كانت الوظيفة مناسبة بشكل طبيعي
بالنسبة لي ، أصعب شيء هو البقاء
مستيقظًا  لذا ، فإن الشخير
يوقظك ، هذا في الواقع ما مشكلتي هو أنني أرتدي cpap بنفسي
قبل أن أصبح تقنية نوم ، كنت
مريضًا جدًا ،
ولم يكن لدي أي فكرة عن السبب
، ثم تم تشخيصي
بانقطاع النفس النومي
الشديد وعندما تم علاجي من  من خلال
آلة cpap ، فقد أنقذ حياتي حرفيًا
وهو مو  أعطتني وحفزتني للدخول
إلى الميدان ، عادةً ما أعمل ثلاث
ليالٍ في الأسبوع ثلاث نوبات من ثلاث عشرة ساعة ، هل
هي صعبة ، نعم ، هناك بعض الليالي
التي تكون أقسى من غيرها ، ولكن إذا كنت
أعمل ثلاث ليالٍ متتالية ، فأنا
عادةً ما تكون أربع أربع ليالٍ.  ونصف يوم
إجازة متتالية ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لقد رأيت القليل
حتى تتمكن من قضاء المزيد من الوقت
في المنزل مع عائلتك للقيام بما
تحب القيام به
فقط
عندما ننتهي من الاتصال
أذهب إلى غرفة التكنولوجيا ،
هناك شيء يسمى
المعايرة الحيوية يعطيني صوت شخير عالي
أفضل ما يمكنك
، وبدأت الدراسات رسميًا
تحصل على الأسئلة المعتادة مثل كيف
تتوقع مني أن أنام مع كل هذه
الأشياء على هذا ما هي عليه دائمًا  اسأل بشكل
صحيح
ثم خرجوا في غضون خمس
دقائق ،
عادةً ما يستغرق إعداد كل مريض نصف ساعة ، حيث سيقضي التقنيون
بقية الليل في مراقبة
الموجات الدماغية وعمل الرئة
أثناء البقاء مستيقظين.
استراتيجيات ey ، الكثير من
الدردشة ، أنا سعيد لأنني لم أحب
مشاهدة اللعبة تبدو وكأنها لعبة جيدة ، لكن
لا أحد يلعب بشكل خاص
محادثة حقيقية هي ترياق قوي للإيماء
بالإيماء بالطبع البشر هم من ينامون ليلاً بشكل طبيعي
وتقنيات النوم  في بعض الأحيان
ما زلنا بحاجة إلى القليل من المساعدة لهذا السبب نحن
نأخذ القهوة حتى لا نمتلك
تلك اللحظات المفاجئة ، نعم
أتمنى الموت يوقظنا دائمًا
لذا يا صديقي على cpap ولكن
حتى الآن كان يتجول في التلفاز ونام
معه حتى  على الرغم من أنني
أخبرته بإيقاف تشغيله ،
فليس لدى كل شخص مشكلة في النوم الجسدي في
بعض الأحيان ، فهو عامل خارجي
مثل ضعف النظافة أثناء النوم ، مثل السماح لي
بتصفح الإنترنت ، دعني أشاهد بعض
مقاطع الفيديو وكل ما تفعله أثناء قيامك
بذلك بدلاً من  الاسترخاء
والذهاب للنوم يحفز عقلك
ويبقي نفسك مستيقظًا ،
لذلك عندما أعمل ،
أهرع إلى المنزل
وأجعل منزلي كهفًا مظلمًا
للغاية وأنام أثناء النهار ،
وعادة ما أحصل على حوالي ست إلى سبع ساعات ،
إنه ليس كذلك  من السهل علينا الذهاب للنوم
مباشرة بعد المناوبة ،
علينا العودة إلى المنزل
،
وربما ساعة ونصف بالنسبة لي ، الشيء الوحيد
الذي يحبط خططي يحتوي على
هذا الجيش من تنسيق الحدائق وهو مثل
طائرة نفاثة خارج نافذتك
إنها
3 54
صباحًا استيقظ مريضي للتو ويواجه
صعوبة في العودة إلى النوم ، وكان لديه
العديد من الدورات العينية.
يبحث التقنيون
عن دورة ريم أخيرة قبل أن
يستيقظ المريض وينتهي الليل
من الاختبار في غضون 30 دقيقة ، فأنت تريد
إخباري إذا كنت تريد إنهاءها في
بعض الأحيان ، فستحصل على مريض
سيقول لك يا ذلك عندما  تستيقظ ستستيقظ من
الأشياء ، أوشكت على الانتهاء من
خلع كل شيء
، وعادة ما أخبرهم إذا وجدت
وظيفة يمكنك الحصول عليها مقابل النوم ،
فأخبرني
لأنني مستيقظ طوال الليل أشاهدك
وأخذ  أهتم بك يقول يا أخي
[موسيقى]